leopold prinz von bayern unterwegs in
seinen bmw 326 aus den späten 30er
jahren in münchen
mit diesem oldtimer ist der ehemalige
rennfahrer besonders eng verbunden
man muss ja wissen man habe in der alte
dame die man jetzt hier also mit der
einfach ganz behutsam umgeht mit ihr
weil die ist natürlich von 1939 das ist
ein paar jahre her aber man muss ich
schnell fahren planiert einfach auf der
straße mit diesem auto zum ersten mal
besucht er das neue oldtimer zentrum bmw
classic auf 13.000 quadratmetern dreht
sich hier alles um die historie des
unternehmens neben werkstätten in denen
autos repariert und restauriert werden
werden auch modelle aus der 100-jährigen
firmengeschichte ausgestellt prinz
leopold kennt einige sowie den bmw 328
ich kenne das auto aus dem effeff und
ich weiß was der macht und wie er sich
verhält und ich liebe das auto ist
einfach auch von einer form von von
seinem fahrverhalten er wenn du so viel
zig tausende meilen auf dem auto
gefahren bist dann ist es ja ans herz
gewachsen ich hätte gerne aber es
springt mein geldbeutel
wer sich nicht gleich einen klassiker
kaufen möchte kann sich hier einen
mieten seit mehr als 30 jahren trägt
klaus gutscher oldtimer aus der ganzen
welt für die sammlung zusammen diesen
507 hat er in den usa in einer scheune
gefunden er gehörte elvis presley
zur zeit wird er original getreue
restauriert
die 70er jahre mit rautenmuster
abgesteppt also autor hatte sehr sehr
wenig wiedererkennungswert vom interieur
und von der mechaniker mit einem bmw 507
vor 100 jahren begann in dieser halle
die geschichte der bayerischen
motorenwerke zunächst mit
flugzeugmotoren das unternehmen hat das
areal mit den denkmalgeschützten
gebäuden vor einigen jahren zurück
gekauft und mit modernen bauten ergänzt
manfred grunert ist verantwortlich für
das konzept und die architektur der bmw
classic eine investition für das image
der automobilmarke
wenn man also 100 jahre alt wird dann
ist es schon auch ein verdienst also
dann hat es schon auch bedeutung und
dass man natürlich diese bedeutung auch
in form von traditionspflege
unterstreichen möchte liegt in der natur
der sache also das hebt einem jahr von
anderen nämlich die eben nicht so alt
geworden sind was tatsächlich nicht
kopierbar ist geschichte von der 100
jährigen erfahrung profitieren nicht nur
kunden wie leopold prinz von bayern
schließlich soll die fahrzeuge so
originalgetreu wie möglich sein nicht
schwarz wir haben hier anhand der
fahrgestellnummer kann klaus gutscher
nun in den unterlagen aus dem archiv
feststellen wo wann und mit welcher
ausstattung bmw das auto ausgeliefert
hat ein eindeutiges indiz dafür ob der
schalker ob weiß oder schwarz ist hier
im verkaufsprospekt ist er schwarz
abgebildet
in zwei wochen wird das ersatzteil
geliefert und anschließend eingebaut
wir haben einfach mehr erfahrung wie die
anderen hier bist du aufgehoben hier
bist du richtig aufkommen hier weißt du
genau dass wenn das auto abholt dann
funktioniert weil es am alten auto
fährst hätte eh nicht auf der automarkt
auf die landstraße geliebtes genießen
freut sich wenn die leute winken